c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir le malick claque la porte
au g5 sahel et à sa force anti
djihadistes bamako accuse l'organisation
d'être instrumentalisé par l'extérieur
il ne reste donc plus que quatre pays
membres décryptage en direct avec ses
dikaba journaliste et spécialiste du sel
manifestations politiques interdites en
guinée une décision des militaires au
pouvoir elle intervient quelques jours
après l'adoption d'une transition de
trois ans par l'organe législatif mis en
place après le coup d'état les réactions
à conakry dans ce journal
nouveau président un nouveau président à
la tête de la somalie il s'appelle
hassan cheikh mahmoud il revient au
pouvoir après cinq ans d'absence les
défis qu'il devra relever sont énormes
les détails dans ce jour
le g5 sahel devient le g4 sahel le mali
a claqué la porte de l'organisation
l'accusant d'être à la solde d'une
puissance extérieure les conséquences
dans la région secouée par l'insécurité
à terroristes vont se faire sentir pour
en parler c'est dikaba journaliste
spécialiste du sahel et du jihadisme et
en particulier de boko haram auteur de
plusieurs livres sur la question est
notre invité ce soir
merci c'est dikaba d'être avec nous
bonsoir alors je rappelle simplement à
nos téléspectateurs que vous et votre
dernier ouvrage s'intitule mali sahel
notre afghanistan à nous voilà on va le
voir s'afficher sur nos écrans alors
c'est dikaba est ce vraiment une
surprise que le mali quitte le g5 sahel
on voyait venir cette menace de retrait
du mali 10,5 celle à partir du moment où
le g5 1 n'a pas retenu sa 8ème
conférence des chefs d'état qui était
normalement prévu au premier trimestre
de l'année 2022
on savait quelque chose se passait et on
n'avait pas envisagé que le mali ceretti
russell ont pensé à plutôt à un
compromis qui amènerait les états du g5
celle à se réunir à mort de rire à
défaut de venir tous à bamako
malheureusement l'option duré 13 s'est
imposé puisque en dépit des différentes
négociations il n'a pas été possible de
tenir le gel et le 8e sommet des chefs
d'états qui normalement auraient pu se
tenir aurait dû se tenir à augmenter
alors bamako qui parle d'une force à la
solde d'une puissance extérieure fait
clairement allusion à la france oui
c'est exact c'est qu'ils aient arrêté
nier c'est surtout le caractère inédit
de la non tenue du sommet depuis la
création du g5 celle à 2014 chaque année
il s'est tenu un sommet des chefs d'état
et le pays hôte deviendra prend la
présidence en exercice pour une période
de 12 mois et au delà même à de
l'accueil du sommet et ce n'est pas le
chef d'état du pays hôte qui réunit mkii
élu président en mai le le pays
c'est pas le chef de table le pays
puisque on peut le voir dans le cas du
tchad en février 2000 à 21
le président deby a été élu président du
g5 sahel pour l'année 2020 et à son
décès en avril 2021 c'est le présent
mama débit qui est devenu le fils qui
est devenu le président et remplace son
fils qui est devenu le présent avec des
si cette tradition de tenir le sommet ça
allait dans un pays du g5 à tour de rôle
et que le pays qui porte devient s'est
perpétuée jusqu'à ce que la situation se
présente et qu'on ne puisse pas tenir le
sommet on ne peut pas ne pas faire le
lien entre la non tenue du pont du
sommet et les difficultés les relations
interdits s'ils exécrables entre la
france et le mali entre le mali et
lugnorre
alors c'est dikaba comment les forces du
désormais g4 celles ci on l'appelle
comme ça vont travailler avec les femmes
à les forces armées maliennes voir avec
l'autre partenaire du mali la russie y
compris le groupe de mercenaires privés
russe wagner
dans cette zone où les frontières sont
poreuses on sait que le terrorisme
traverse les frontières très facilement
non si on ne trouve pas un compromis il
faut le dire très clairement pour que le
mali revient dans le jeu sexuel ça veut
dire que le geste xl est mort il n'y a
pas de possibilité de faire un g4 celle
le g5 sel a été conçu pour mutualiser et
les moyens pour échanger et pour mettre
en place un certain nombre de
dispositions pour lutter contre le
terrorisme le g5 celle à son crédit un
certain nombre de décisions importantes
notamment la possibilité le droit de
poursuite automatique pour que le pays
qui a attaqué puisse entrer dans l'autre
pays du g5 serre sur 50 que le match
sans autorisation le g5 ça elle a
également créé une école de temps majeur
avant à nouakchott le g5 celle à
instaurer le principe poids de la
suppression des visas et il a même conçu
un programme d'urgence de développement
pour que la lutte contre le terrorisme
inclut le volet développement drogue il
ya un certain nombre d'acquis qui ne
peuvent se poursuivre sans le mali parce
que commencer la menace terroriste est
parti du magny pour se reprendre au sel
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune possibilité
d'existence du 5 c'est ça le mali parce
que c'est là l'épicentre des activités
terroristes et je ne vois pas très
sincèrement et objectivement comment on
pourrait faire un jeu car c'est parce
que l'exclusion du mali signifierait un
art de moi mais la bonne nouvelle à mon
avis est que il y a encore une
possibilité de voir comment le g5 sel
peut retrouver un fonctionnement normal
alors à terme la france devra-t-elle se
retirer complètement de la région le
sentiment anti français on le retrouve
pas qu'au mali il est aussi au burkina
faso au tchad également on a vu ce
dimanche une manifestation anti français
ce week-end n'djamena est ce que la
france va finir par devoir quitter la
région moi je ne pense pas que
ce soit une bonne chose que la france
partent mais il faut que la france la
france trouvera sa place à l'intérieur
du dispositif
qu'il n'ya plus d'exclusivité pour que
pour la présence française la france à
côté d'eux d'autres partenaires à sa
place aux ailes on parle souvent de la
russie et wagner à tort moi je pense que
l'un des principaux acteurs nouveaux
acteurs de cette sous région c'est la
turquie la turquie aujourd'hui en train
de gagner en influence à la fois sur le
plan politique économique même sur le
plan militaire parce qu'un certain
nombre de pays dont le niger et le
burkina vient d'acheter du matériel
militaire dont dépendra la turquie donc
il ya une place pour la france il ya une
place pour d'autres acteurs et la france
ne peut même avoir une place importante
à condition de voir dans quel secteur
elle a en a pas un avantage comparatif
par rapport aux opérateurs elle a une
longue tradition de coopération avec ces
pays je pense que elle peut continuer à
être présente mais à côté d'autres
acteurs et si cela ne pas penser et si
on raisonne en termes d'activité comme
ça puisse se faire par le passé interne
de pré carré où la france doit dicter
les choses d'en sortir merci beaucoup
c'est dikaba journaliste spécialiste du
sel et auteur du livre malice elle notre
afghanistan ce à nous merci pour votre
décryptage aucun plaisir
en guinée les militaires au pouvoir ont
annoncé à l'interdiction des
manifestations politiques de rue une
interdiction qui intervient à quelques
jours après l'adoption d'une transition
de trois ans par l'organe législatif mis
en place après le coup d'état une
décision qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
la correspondance à conakry de malines
diakité
les principaux partis politiques la
société civile les ong de défense des
droits de l'homme né décolère pas ses
acteurs avaient annoncé des
manifestations de rue pour dénoncer le
manque de dialogue entre les politiques
et les militaires au pouvoir mais aussi
pour s'opposer à la durée de la
transition porté à 36 mois par le cnt le
conseil national de la transition pour
le fn décès le front national pour la
défense de la constitution long des
principaux regroupements du pays il
n'est pas question de se soumettre à
cette injonction des militaires au
pouvoir nous avons fait par notre
opposition farouche à se soumettre aux
dictats du cnrd le cnrd et dans une
volonté de confiscation du pouvoir
raison pour laquelle au même moment
qu'il communique sur le délai de la
transition
ils interdisent la possibilité des
citoyens d'exprimer leur opposition à
travers une manifestation de rue loger
dh organisation guinéenne de défense des
droits de l'homme a quant à elle exprime
son inquiétude en ce qui concerne le
respect des droits et de libertés des
citoyens ce communiqué du cnrd vraiment
c'est quelque chose d'inquiétant pour
nous en tant que défenseur de ballons et
le temps plus que quand même c'est un
communiqué dans un premier temps qui
viole l'esprit de la typique de la
charte de la transition qui garantit en
tout cas les droits et libertés des
citoyens mais également cette convention
internationale et donc nous estimons que
elle n'avait pas le budget malgré cette
interdiction les principaux partis
politiques et la société civile menace
toujours de descendre très prochainement
dans la rue pour s'opposer à la durée de
la transition en cours le cnrd de son
côté prévient que tout manquement à
cette interdiction entre nra pour leurs
auteurs des conséquences de droit ce
nouveau massacre en république
démocratique du congo au moins 20 civils
ont été tués la semaine dernière en
ituri dans le nord-est du pays l'attaqué
est attribuée aux rebelles adf
originaire de l'ouganda voisin l'accès
sur les lieux du massacre est difficile
pour des raisons sécuritaires
la croix rouge locale n'a pas pu
confirmer ce bilan mais a précisé avoir
été informé du massacre d'au moins 30
personnes
la somalie est un nouveau président pas
si nouveau que ça assène cheikh mahmoud
revient aux affaires après avoir quitté
le pouvoir pendant cinq ans le chef de
l'état fraîchement élu à face à lui
plusieurs grands défis l'insurrection
djihadiste des shebab une crise
économique et une sécheresse qui fait
planer l'ombre de la famine dans le pays
mais il devra avant tout rassembler et
unifier une classe politique divisée les
explications de le renverser cher
félicité par le président sortant le
regard du nouveau chef d'état somalien
se tourne déjà vers l'avenir
pensons à demain base arrière et à ce
qui s'est passé je travaillerai à un
avenir brillant et un bel avenir pour
que mon peuple puisse vivre dignement
[Musique]
hassan sheikh mohamud n'en est pas à son
premier coup d'essai il avait déjà
dirigé la somalie entre 2012 et 2017
ancien universitaire et militant des
droits de l'homme il s'était forgé une
réputation de pacifistes ouvert d'esprit
est tolérant mais son mandat avait été
entaché par des accusations de
corruption il hérite aujourd'hui d'un
pays instable miné par une insurrection
djihadistes une sécheresse historique et
une crise économique qui ne cesse
d'empirer
des défis auxquels le nouveau président
devra s'attaquer sans attendre
j'espère qu'il créera des emplois pour
les jeunes au chômage qui vivent dans
une situation difficile
ils devraient se concentrer sur la
sécurité et traduire en justice tous
soldats du gouvernement qui tue des gens
sans raison
c'est un sage et un aîné qui peut
travailler avec tous les partis
politiques somaliens
mais avant de commencer à construire
hassan sheikh mohamud devra d'abord
réparer les dégâts du mandat de son
prédécesseur et réconcilier une classe
politique plus fracturées que jamais
après un an et demi de crise
et sachets concernant la lutte contre
les djihadistes que le président
américain joe biden a approuvé le
rétablissement d'une présence militaire
américaine en somalie pour lutter contre
les shebab quelque 750 militaires
américains déployés dans ce pays avait
été rappelé il y a dix huit mois par
l'administration trump les soldats des
forces spéciales américaines seront de
nouveau stationnés dans le pays mais
leur nombre sera réduit à 500 hommes
on en vient à cette polémique suscitée
par l'absence d'idrissa gueye ce samedi
lors du match du paris saint-germain en
ligue 1 un match qui a coïncidé avec la
journée internationale de lutte contre
l'homophobie le joueur n'aurait pas
souhaité manni se manifester son soutien
à la communauté lgbt selon le parisien
plus de détails avec notre correspondant
à dakar elimane dao
pour le moment il n'ya pas encore d'une
version officielle précise sur l'absence
de drissa dyana gaye ce samedi lors de
la 37e journée de la ligue 1 et la
rencontre opposant le paris saint
germain et montpellier son entraîneur
mauricio pochettino en conférence de
presse d'après-match a évoqué des
raisons personnelles son entourage n'a
pas encore réagi mais selon le parisien
et rmc sport et drissa dagnogo ne
voulait pas porter le maillot parisien
floqué du drapeau arc en ciel à soutien
à la communauté lgbt i lors de la
journée internationale de lutte contre
l'homophobie
une version qui ne plaît pas aux
associations de défense de cette
communauté en france mais au sénégal le
joueur qui jouit d'une forte cote de
popularité est soutenu à part les
sénégalais qui appelle à ce que
l'opinion personnelle des joueurs soient
respectés à cette polémique intervient
juste quelques jours après
l'organisation en grande pompe de la
soirée caritative de l'association aude
et drissa gana guèye à paris avec la
présence de grandes stars du football
mondial comme neymar messi ou kylie ann
pape et ses coéquipiers ou pas laisser
germer une soirée organisée pour venir
en aide aux enfants malades du cancer et
du vih sida
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique restait avec nous dans
quelques instants la suite de paris
direct avec audrey racines
[Musique]